Salut, aujourd'hui on est dans les loges du grand point virgule
et on vient de finir les hallucinations collectives
et autres illusions fantastiques
Et là il se passe un truc de fou, y a Georgio qui va essayer de mentaliser Farid du grand Show Time
Donc Farid a beaucoup d'argent, enfin beaucoup d'argent pour lui
Pour Farid, c'est énorme, c'est énorme, c'est énorme
Je vais garder deux petites pièces et tu vas ranger le reste
D'accord, je mets tout dans ma poche arrière
Poche arrière droite, très important, du pantalon vert bouteille
Alors ce qu'on va faire c'est que, regarde tu vas fermer les mains
Et ce que je vais faire c'est que je vais essayer de changer la pièce de 1 euro avec la pièce de 50 cts
ce qui va se passer c'est que je vais faire de l'autohypnose, d'accord?
Et en fait, tu vas pas te rendre compte
mais tu vas avoir ce qu'on appelle un micro sommeil
-D'accord
-Ce qui va me permettre d'ouvrir les mains
de changer les pièces et de te remettre les mains devant
-C'est incroyable hein?
-Ok
Je vais te montrer avec Julie
Je vais te montrer comment ça marche, parce que les gens ne croient pas à l'hypnose
Appuie toi sur ma main, ferme les yeux, appuie toi bien fort
Ferme les yeux, et tac elle dort
-T'as vu ça va vite hein? Regarde, tu vois!
-C'est ouf
Et là, maintenant, après, on peut faire des trucs et tout ça
-Alors t'es prêt?
-Oui
Attention on y va, ce que je vais faire c'est que je vais passer d'une main à l'autre,
tu fais attention, tu me laisses faire? Tu sens ou pas là?
-Bah, euh... ouais, ça commence à... je sais pas
Est-ce que tu sens que c'est en train de passer d'une main à l'autre?
Là je sens, je sers bien les pièces
C'est bon ça y est, vas-y
Ah merde... c'est raté
Je suis désolé... Tu sais quoi? Je vais t'offrir un cadeau
Je vais t'offrir un cadeau à 1 euro
Tiens hop
-C'est énorme!
-Je suis désolé, je pouvais pas plus qu'un euro
-Mais c'est ma montre que tu m'as pris
-Ah d'accord
-C'est ma montre que tu m'as pris
-Ca te fais plaisir?
-Ouais, ça me fait très plaisir
-Julie je vais t'offrir ta culotte
-Ca me fait très plaisir, en plus elle est à ma taille
-Est-ce ça te plaît? La couleur te plaît?
-La couleur me plaît écoute très bien!
-Parce que c'est difficile de choisir un cadeau pour les gens
-En fait, j'ai vraiment plus de culotte...
-C'est moi qui l'ai, c'est moi qui l'ai
-Mais en fait, c'est 20 cts
C'était dans le cul de ...
-Bravo Georgio!
-Merci beaucoup
Georgio joue les jeudis et vendredis et samedis au théâtre du Trévise
avec Mental expert 1et Mental expert 2
et bientôt Mental expert 3
-Bientôt, bientôt
-Et le 4 aussi
-Eh, faut pas trop en mettre parce que là, tu les, tu les..
-Bah oui c'est ça
Et la troupe du Grand Show Time que vous pouvez retrouver au point virgule
les vendredis et samedis et une fois par mois au grand point virgule
pour une exceptionnelle, en fait et y a  toujours un guest
-Fared t'es vraiment trop con! Fared est trop con
-Tout le monde me prend ma montre ce soir, j'en ai d'autres
J'espère que ça vous a plu, je vous donne rendez-vous demain à 11h
pour le prochain mental vlog, tchao!